- "Which of the following values
"is equal to the value above?"
And we got this expression here
with a bunch of negative
fractional exponents.
And at first you might say
how do I deal with this?
Maybe I don't know what
the fifth root of three is,
much less the negative fifth root,
and this 1/3 to the negative 2/5,
how do I simplify this?
And the key realization here is that
1/3 is the same thing as three
to the negative one power.
And we if do that I
suspect that we're going
to be able to get similar bases here.
Let me rewrite the whole thing.
So it's gonna be three to the negative 1/5
times, instead of writing 1/3,
I could write three to
the negative one power,
to the negative 2/5 power
and now we could just use up
our straight exponent rules
to simplify things a little bit.
So this business right over here
that I'm squaring this orange color,
if I raise something to an exponent
and then raise it again
to another exponent
that's going to be the same thing
as taking our original raise
and raising it to the negative one times,
the negative one times negative 2/5 power.
So I can raise, if I raise
it to the negative one
and then to the negative 2/5
that's the same thing as raising three
to the negative one
times negative 2/5 power.
And so and this one over here is still
going to be three to the negative 1/5.
And so this is going to be
equal to three to the negative,
three to the negative 1/5 times,
now negative one times negative 2/5,
that's gonna be positive 2/5,
so times three to the 2/5,
and now we have a situation
where we have the same base,
we have the product of
three to the negative 1/5
times three to the positive 2/5,
this is going to be equal to,
we can take our base three,
it's gonna be three to the negative 1/5
plus 2/5 power, plus 2/5 power.
If you have the same base,
the product of that base
raised to one exponent
and that same base raised
to another exponent
that's the same thing as that base raised
to the sum of those exponents.
A classic exponent property.
I encourage you to go onto Khan Academy
if this is looking foreign
or if you need some review.
But now this is pretty straightforward.
This is going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal
to three to the negative 1/5
plus 2/5 is just 1/5.
And there you have it,
three to the 1/5 power.